hey guys it's Jonah here are you ready
for another challenge so a couple of
months ago I challenged you to a 10,000
watts challenged it was so inspiring to
see oil pictures on Instagram and
Facebook and congratulations to all of
you who completed the challenge this
time we want to do a 1,000 our do and
core burn challenge so if traditional
code you like running cycling is not
your thing
well this challenge is for you so we
want to slowly progress through the
workout the first week the goal is to
complete 250 repetitions second week
five hundred repetitions but week 750
repetitions and the final week you want
to really push yourself and do 1,000
repetitions so the goal is to do this
workout at least three times weekly okay
your body wants up give me your best
effort and let's burn together there
will be ten exercises each workout we
want to complete 25 repetitions so the
entire set will be 250 repetitions okay
the first workout will be jumping jacks
and I will let you know each workout as
we move on
so get your body ready and let's go with
jumping jacks let's go one do to as wide
as the can and remember to touch okay
nice keep going pay the breathing this
is just the first workout take it easy
take this as your warmup round get ten
more nine plus five four three two and
one very good and now just check it out
second workout to on your lower body we
want to focus on squats okay so I showed
it with the pot let's get down into a
nice deep squat let's go one two three
good remember to always push with your
hoop or went crucially the you just keep
pointing back chest up back straight
okay do not launch forward go as low
you can see squat if you are really
crazy then you know what get into a hot
squat okay three seven more four five
six seven eight
nice nice one hand very good next
workout Jesus
all right so left and right will be one
okay so I'm going to hop to my left one
that's one degree too good reach down
three four good point
balance side good six keep going
so find your balance look straight ahead
and really engage your core muscles to
find your balance
good inter breathing whoa that's ten
more okay
so find your balance stay low and really
engage your butt muscles and your legs
keep going plus 5 for 11 rise 1 3 2 & 1
good shake it out good pop workout let's
get down onto the mat and let's do
push-up okay so on your knees or on your
toes if you want more challenge right
pump twice let's get down and lower the
can push are good too good
threes remember back flat okay do not do
this this is wrong by slide and go very
good keep going gaze gently at the floor
all right keep your neck and your
shoulders relaxed so if you want to
progress you can get onto your toes okay
and do a full push-up good so going oh
if it's not easy but keep pushing
yourself or get back down onto your
knees
halfway through for
three two one
and just rest it out we want to move on
to the most dreaded workout but it's
really good for your core as well
mountain climbers alright so again start
in a high plank position and climb left
and right is one let's go up right one
two three four good 5 6 7 8 9 10 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 20 left 5 1 2 3 4 5 ah very
well done
moving on plank jacks ok so again on a
high plank position jump in and out
let's get down and go 1 2 3 count with
me
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 good 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 20
left 5 2 3 4 5 well by this time you
should feel your heart rate pumping you
should be sweating
let's move on to the hip thrust so get
down to the floor okay I want you to lie
on to the floor bring your heels
close your butt my not too close and all
I want to do is imagine there's a string
pulling you up okay the left side now up
breather but to squeeze slow it down
shut up okay don't rest it just tap for
squeeze you're listening from your butt
and your belly okay not from your
shoulders
good keep going squeeze right the top
hold the one count and really engage
your butt muscles if you want to
challenge yourself even more
you can't even place a pair of light
dumbbells on your hips and push it up
good
going squeeze and gauge ensuring that
contraction throughout last 10 10 good
nice very nice
it squeeze 7 9 6 plus 5 more by good for
squeeze control 3 control relaxed
shoulders two last one and I want you to
hold it
one holy five four three squeeze two one
drop it down and give your butt a nice
pat okay still like down we want to move
on to crunches all right so again you
just click your butt and just extend
your arms and just crunch and tap your
knees
okay focus on your upper abs let's go
one two three four
remember lift your shoulders off and do
not strain your neck okay good
the crunch and the muscles that you will
see focused on either core not your neck
muscles okay good just gently gaze ahead
controlled out last help you keep going
crunch without last five five four
control three control two and one
very good we have worked on our upper
application now we want to focus on the
lower app alright the leg straight let's
get straight into flutter kick against
left and right will be one let's go
bring it up one two three four five good
six seven eight nine ten one two small
movement okay good seven eight nine ten
one two three four five oh my god can
you feel the ABS Bernie good keep that
burning going let's get up and finish
with a solid cardio and really we're
going to chorus all in an out squat jump
okay
wife all right let's go tap dance one
good - good keep going really for your
inner thighs working and really push
your heart rate back up nice keep going
don't stop right now see your sweat
dripping on the floor and we want to
bring your heart rate back up don't dive
for the upper body squat low down left
ten nine eight seven tap
six plus five four
good keep going three I know your
autograph those two right now - last one
and well done so that was ten exercises
25 repetitions each and in total you did
250 repetitions for one step okay so
slowly progress and keep increasing the
repetitions each week god the goal is to
achieve one thousand repetitions at the
end of your fourth week so let's do this
cardio and core burning challenge
together I am drenched in sweat this is
a great way to Palm your heart rate to
boost the metabolism and it to replace
those boring cardio with something more
interesting plus you can do this workout
anywhere and anytime you can also print
this workout challenge from my website
click on the link in my description box
below so be sure to like this video
share this video with your friends
Katniss to join you in this challenge
and do subscribe to my youtube channel
for a lot more workout challenge recipes
and fitness tips don't forget to also
turn on the notification button so that
you will get notified every time I
upload a new video all the best and dude
tag me and share your pictures with me
on instagram and facebook at to another
official bye
burn it all